Traduttore: Annie Doms
Revisore: Elena Pedretti
Natale del 2009
sarà un periodo che difficilmente
riuscirò a dimenticare.
Mi ero imbattuto pochi mesi prima
in un articolo giornalistico
su un settimanale,
che parlava di mais
geneticamente modificato,
i cosiddetti "OGM".
E l'articolo era assolutamente categorico:
ci spiegava che quel mais nuoce
alla salute umana,
è già nelle nostre bistecche
e può causare gravissime allergie.
Sorpreso di queste affermazioni
così categoriche
scrivo al direttore del giornale
e gli domando se esista
un documento scientifico
alla base di affermazioni
tanto categoriche.
Ne nasce un dibattito acceso.
Dopodiché aspetto la settimana successiva,
non c'è nessuna smentita sul settimanale
e quindi ricostruisco l'intera vicenda
sul mio blog,
affermando due cose:
che non c'è nessun dato scientifico
alla base dell'articolo giornalistico
e che l'esperto intervistato nell'articolo
non ha mai parlato col giornalista
autore del pezzo.
Così, a Natale del 2009,
ricevo una denuncia penale
per diffamazione.
Ora, se a denunciarvi
è la Compagnia di San Paolo,
che assume per l'occasione
gli avvocati del Corriere della Sera,
se la richiesta finanziaria di indennizzo
è 400.000 euro,
se a denunciarvi è un giornale
da mezzo milione di copie
che si chiama Famiglia Cristiana,
capirete perché è difficile passare
delle serene festività natalizie.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Ora,
questa storia andrà avanti
ancora per quattro anni,
finché una giudice non sentenzierà
che io ero risalito alle fonti originali
di conoscienza
e che era scritto il falso
nell'articolo giornalistico
di Famiglia Cristiana.
Contentezza per una vicenda giudiziaria
finita bene?
No.
Tristezza.
Tristezza di essere stato
incapace di parlare
a Famiglia Cristiana, di scambiarci
opinioni, documenti.
Tristezza di aver lasciato i lettori
nello sconcerto, soprattutto di non aver -
di aver visto tanta sfiducia
in un prestigioso settimanale
su un'innovazione scientifica.
Ma soprattutto,
è un caso eccezionale di distanza
fra scienza e società civile
o succede spesso?
Io temo che succeda piuttosto spesso
e di bufale scientifiche ne vediamo
in continuazione,
a partire da quella dei vaccini
correlati all'autismo,
un guaio che mette in grande difficoltà
l'intero Paese.
Ma come non ricordare la vicenda
del professor Di Bella,
la sua cura per il cancro,
che ha paralizzato la ricerca oncologica
in questo Paese per un anno intero,
ponendo sfiducia nelle chemioterapie.
Bruno Vespa ha scritto un libro
con il professor Di Bella
e tanti politici sono saltati
su quel carro.
Come dimenticare la recente vicenda
della professoressa Ilaria Capua,
linciata sulla stampa nazionale,
poi incolpata di reati così gravi
che prevedevano anche l'ergastolo,
poi riabilitata,
fuggita all'estero,
dimessasi dal parlamento senza che nessuno
le chiedesse scusa.
E come scordarsi, non so, della vicenda
della sentenza in primo grado
per tutta la Commissione Grandi Rischi,
quella del terremoto de L'Aquila:
sei anni di reclusione
a tutta la commissione
per non aver allertato la popolazione
sulla possibilità di un rischio
di un terremoto.
E gli esempi possono
andare avanti quanto volete.
Natale dell'anno scorso:
la Procura della Repubblica di Lecce
mette sotto indagine
cinque scienziati e cinque amministratori.
Gli scienziati sono colpevoli
di aver trovato la realtà,
cioè che c'è un batterio,
Xylella fastidiosa,
nel Salento,
responsabile della morìa degli ulivi.
Gli amministratori sono responsabili
di aver attuato, o voler attuare,
le procedure in caso di emergenza
per un'epidemia come questa.
Xylella è un patogeno da quarantena.
Ma la Procura della Repubblica di Lecce
ci vede dei sordidi giochi
di multinazionali
che vogliono spargere erbicidi:
nota che la multinazionale Monsanto,
sette anni prima, ha acquistato
un'altra azienda biotecnologica
di nome Allelyx.
Ora, "allele" per un genetista
è un termine corrente:
sono due geni che vengono
da due organismi diversi
e svolgono la stessa funzione.
Ma la Procura ci vede
una cosa diversa:
scrive
che Allelyx
è il palindromo di Xylella.
Il palindromo!
Cioè, la Settimana Enigmistica
può servire
per svelare i sordidi intrighi
delle multinazionali!
A questo siamo ridotti in questo Paese.
(Applausi)
Ma soprattutto il problema è:
come fa un singolo magistrato
a discernere
tra esperti autorevoli
a livello internazionale
e ciarlatani?
Come fa da solo a capire
chi è la persona a cui affidarsi?
Guardate, io ho lavorato tanti anni
al Pasteur a Parigi.
Il direttore del Pasteur
è sempre stato un consulente
del primo ministro francese.
Per non parlare di quello che succede
alla Royal Society,
che scrive in continuazione
documenti tecnici
che fanno da base
per le scelte, poi, dei politici.
Come dimenticare che il presidente Obama
va alla National Accademy of Sciences
negli Stati Uniti
a parlare della "visione" che lui ha
della ricerca scientifica.
Quando mai abbiamo sentito
un nostro politico parlarci
della sua "visione" della ricerca
scientifica?
Eppure saremmo la patria
di Galileo Galilei,
del metodo scientifico.
Ma noi non ci crediamo più
nel metodo scientifico.
Guardate,
stamattina Piero Angela ci parlava
della divulgazione scientifica.
L'Italia ha una legge per la diffusione
della cultura scientifica.
I fondi a quella legge, l'anno scorso,
sono stati tagliati del 40%
e prima ancora di questo taglio,
i grandi musei italiani,
quelli che fanno divulgazione scientifica,
avevano un budget dieci volte inferiore
dei loro corrispondenti
francesi, tedeschi e inglesi.
Questa è la situazione
nella quale stiamo mettendo -
è quello che ci stiamo giocando.
Noi ci stiamo giocando
i vent'anni prossimi
di possibilità di far crescere
una nuova generazione
di persone competenti di scienza.
Diceva Valerio Albertini, stamattina,
che ci evolviamo
perché finalmente vengono rimossi
quelli della mia generazione
e arrivano i nuovi.
Noi ci stiamo giocando i nuovi!
Rimaniamo noi.
Vi rendete conto del problema?
Questa è la ragione per cui poi
fuggono all'estero.
Fuggono in tutte le categorie all'estero.
Non fuggono solo gli scienziati,
perché quando un Paese declina,
declina in tutte le sue classi
e fuggono tutti per non tornare mai più.
Guardate che non fuggono
solo gli scienziati,
fuggono i pizzaioli
e gli operai specializzati.
Il rapporto di Migrantes
ci ha appena spiegato
che adesso stanno fuggendo
principalmente da Lombardia e Veneto.
Dalle regioni ricche stanno fuggendo.
Questo è quello che ci stiamo giocando
per il nostro futuro:
scappano tutti quanti.
Va bene, voi direte:
"Ma Di Bella, la professoressa
Ilaria Capua, i vaccini,
gli OGM, la Commissione Grandi Rischi,
o gli ulivi del Salento
cosa c'entrano l'uno con l'altro?"
Se lo chiedete a uno scienziato, vi dirà:
"È colpa dei media,
che non sanno scrivere.
È colpa dei magistrati,
che fanno questo e quell'altro.
In tutti i casi è colpa della politica".
Va bene, sì, tutto vero,
ma se io posso dirvi una cosa,
io vi direi un'altra cosa:
se tutto questo è potuto accadere
in questo Paese,
è soprattutto colpa degli scienziati.
È colpa degli scienziati che non hanno
imposto la loro visione.
È colpa degli scienziati,
di alcuni scienziati - ma troppi
in questo Paese -
che hanno pensato alla carriera
o al loro interesse personale
o ad andare a elemosinare
finanziamenti individuali
che sono sempre stati pura elemosina.
Questo è quello che è successo
in questo Paese!
(Applausi)
Se tutto questo è successo,
è perché l'Italia non ha una sola voce.
La scienza non ha una sola voce
per parlare.
Serve un gruppo ristretto,
un coordinamento,
un gruppo identificabile di persone,
poi estremamente ramificato,
capace di entrare
in tutte le discipline del sapere,
a redigere documenti, a fornire opinioni,
soprattutto a fornire rappresentanti
della comunità scientifica
ai media, ai magistrati, alla politica.
Non persone cooptate dalla politica
per annuire alle loro decisioni già prese.
Questa è la cosa che deve cambiare!
Gli scienziati devono identificare
chi sono gli esperti autorevoli
campo per campo,
disciplina per disciplina,
tematica per tematica.
E devono riuscire a farlo
con tutti gli altri attori.
E se questi non vogliono sentire
quello che dice la scienza,
devono essere in grado
di saltare le mediazioni
e arrivare direttamente al pubblico,
come succede in Gran Bretagna
con Sense about Science.
Cioè organizzazioni che mettono
direttamente in contatto
scienziati e pubblico.
Uno scienziato, però,
che si deve spiegare,
aprire,
parlare in termini comprensibili.
Raccontare i fatti,
accogliere le ansie,
le paure, le opinioni.
Avere il tempo di farlo
e agire con i tempi dei media,
che non sono i tempi dell'Accademia,
dei mesi di riunione,
sono tempi immediati.
Le reazioni devono essere all'istante.
Non è possibile pensare che si reagisce
alcune settimane dopo
di fronte a un'emergenza
di qualunque genere.
Ecco, questo è quello che è mancato:
è mancato un coordinamento,
è mancata un'identità,
è mancato un gruppo di coordinamento,
capace di essere riconoscibile
come gli scienziati di questo Paese,
capaci di redigere i documenti,
di fare affermazioni,
di entrare in tutte le discipline.
Capaci
di fare quello che ci diceva
Valerio Albertini stamattina:
se non riusciamo a proporre
una nuova visione della scienza,
non recupereremo nessuno
delle centinaia, delle migliaia di ragazzi
che abbiamo espulso,
che abbiamo mandato all'estero,
senza più nessuna speranza
di farli tornare,
perché non c'è meritocrazia,
non c'è logica,
non c'è nulla di tutto questo.
L'abbiamo sentito in tutti questi giorni,
da Raffaele Cantone con le parentopoli
delle università fino in giù.
Allora, o cambia profondamente
questo sistema
o noi non riusciremo a far tornare
tutti questi ragazzi
e solo loro ci possono aiutare
a tracciare una nuova rotta
per questo Paese,
un po' più civile,
un po' più democratico.
Grazie.
(Applausi)